ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
เครย์ 3 คู่หญิงแล้วนะคะได้ค่ะวันนี้วัน
อะไรครับผู้หญิง
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ห้อวันที่ห้า
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีคศ
อะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะหมอแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้
เวลา
15:00 น
5 นาที
ก็รอบ่าย 3 โมง 5 นาทีเย้ใหญ่ลบ
ๆลบไปหักผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะครู
เอ๋สบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะแต่คงเอกคิดเสียง
คู๋นครูหญิงฟังชัดไหมคะชัดค่ะ
โอเคนะคะโอเคค่ะ
วันนี้ค่ะนักเรียนนวันนี้ครูเอ๋กับครู
หญิง
เอกผู้หญิงคู๋จะให้คุยอิ๋งน่ะมาวาดรูป
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงต้องคิดเราก็ว่านะคะอ่ะคิด
คิดแล้วก็วาดรูปอา
มันเหมือนแข่งกันแข่งกับโปรเอ๋เอ๋
ได้เลยค่ะ 1888 ต้องว่านอะไรที่ที่ที่ลอย
เข้าใจรอยไหมคะเนี่ยนะอันเนี้ยปากกาถ้ากู
เองเพราะอีกล่ะปากกาตบอ๋อประกาศลอยไม่ได้
อ้ะปากการอยไม่ได้ไม่ลอยแต่งหรือยิงต้อง
วาดวาดอะไรที่ลอยลอยได้ 2 อย่างนะคะอ่ะ
เอาอันที่ 1 ก่อนนะคะ
อันที่หนึ่งมองเห็นไหมค่ะน้องค่ะสีเงิน
เขียนให้ตัวเองอะคุยมีภูเขาใช่ไหมคะนี่
เป็นภูเขาว่าตัวเขาอันเนี้ยท้องฟ้า
ท้องฟ้ามีเมฆ
เมฆน่ะลอยมหาลอยบนท้องฟ้าราคา
รอยบนท้องฟ้า
เพลงอันนี้เป็นรอยที่ 1 อันที่ 2 มี
รอยที่ไหนคะรอยในน้ำ
อา
รอนในน้ำนะคะอะไรที่ลอยในน้ำแต่ว่าครูเอ๋
จะเอารอยที่ท้องฟ้าก่อนได้ค่ะครูเองที่
ท้องฟ้าลอยในอากาศแล้วบ่ป้าอาจนะคะ
เล็กใช่ไหมเหมือนแม่มันแม่นะคะค่ะว่าครู
เอ๋วาด 1 รูปแล้วครูหญิงใครว่านะคะได้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเขาผู้หญิงขีดเส้นแป๊บนึงนะตัวเอง
ลบตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะอ้าว
ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวเขาคุยถึงขีดเส้นแบ่งก่อนจะ
ได้ตรงหุยไม่เท่ากันนะคะนักเรียนโอเคนะคะ
อะไรของผู้หญิงอะไรของคู๋อ่าโอเคของคุณ
เอ๋ที่นี่ค่ะอ่ะอากูเอถ้าตัวเอก
ตอนนี้ของผู้หญิง
คือพื้นไม่เขียนโทรลล์ 4 สีอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋สีฟ้าสีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินสี
น้ำเงิน
ไปวัดเส้นนี้เนาะถ่าย
ของครูหญิงสีเขียว
สีสีเขียวนะดินเขียวงานเคเอาลอยบนฟ้าก่อน
นะคะลอยบนฟ้า
ได้ค่ะ
ใครจะวาดก่อนสีอะไรค่ะให้ครูเอ๋ว่าจอ่อน
ก่อนก่อนนะคะอ่างั้นคุยว่าไปแล้วเมื่อกี้
1 รูปก็ว่าเลยนะคะแม่ค่ะคือเอาไม่เคย
เหรอคุณ
แม่ค่ะแม่กลอยบนท้องฟ้าโปร่ง
ได้ค่ะครูหญิงเอาอันนี้ก็ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
เพลงขอดูอะไรกูเองต้องดูเขาว่าผู้หญิงวาด
อะไร
กูเอโร่ละก็อีกจะว่าอะไรแต่ว่าอะไรว่าหนู
แล้วหรอ
พระเอกคิดว่ารู้อะไรอ่ะไม่ใช่ยังไงกูเอง
ไม่รู้
บอลลูนเก่งมากบอลโลก
ผู้หญิงว่าตรงนี้ผิดนะคะแป๊บนึงนะคะพระ
เอกก็เว่าสวยๆค่ะใช่ใช่แค่นั้นก็พอแล้ว
ไม่ใช่หรออ้อมบอลลูนบอลลูนเนี่ยรอยใน
อากาศค่ะ
แม่ก็ลอยในอากาศลอยบนท้องฟ้าเราจะพูดว่า
ลอยในมีอากาศลอยบนท้องฟ้าเหมือนกันเนาะ
สายกะพี่เอ๋ค่ะเอ๋ก๋วยคิดได้ไหมคะมีอะไร
ที่ลอยบนท้องฟ้าอีกมีค่ะคู่หญิงแต่คนอื่น
ต้องเปลี่ยนสีไหมเนี่ยจะได้เหมือน
พระเจ้า
ถ้าต่อ
สีเหลืองใช่ไหมคะพระจันทร์สีเหลืองเหมือน
พระจันทร์ค่ะคู่หญิงพระจันทร์ลอยบนท้อง
ฟ้าต่อไปดาวแน่ๆได้ครับไม่รู้คิวผู้หญิง
คุยอะไรรอยวนท้องฟ้าครูหญิงดิบอันนี้ดี
กว่ามีค่ะยายน่ะสายมี
อะไรไม่คิดว่าผู้หญิงว่าอะไรอ่ะ
และ
ยานอวกาศเหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะคู๋
อ้า
ยานอวกาศการอวกาศลอยบนท้องฟ้าได้อ๋อโอเค
and คู่หญิงดาวว่านอะไร
ชายอย่านะได้ค่ะคุยเปลี่ยนสีอีกไหมคะสี
น้ำเงินสีเดี๋ยว
พี่ก่อนว่ายังไง
พี่เอ๋ว่างไม่ค่อยเป็น
เว็บเลตเป็นเส้นๆนะคะคุณเห็นครูเอ๋เป็น
เส้นเส้นฮะทำไมเส้นเล็กจังเลยคุยต้อง
เปลี่ยนให้มันเส้นใหญ่ค่ะโอเค
ดูเป็นสี่เหลี่ยม
สี่เหลี่ยมมั้ยเป็น 4 อีกใหม
สี่เหลี่ยมสองอัน
มีอะไรยาวออกมาฮะ
เหมือนมั้ยเหมือนไหม
พาราชูตเหรอไม่ใช่
มั้ยว่าเหมือนไว้อ่ะ
ผู้หญิงดูเร็วๆๆว่าผิดไปว่าผิดเจ้า
ลบแล้วว่านใหม่นะคะ
เอกก็จำไม่ค่อยได้นักเรียน
อ้ะฮึ
ว่าเหมือนสี่เหลี่ยม assy ระดับนี้คิดว่า
นะผู้หญิงคิดว่าพี่สี่เหลี่ยมใหญ่ๆเล็กๆ
ใหญ่มากใส่ใหญ่ไปใหญ่ไปจะเสร็จไหมคะอ่ะกะ
เสร็จไหมคะวันนี้จะวาดได้ใช่นั่นสิกูยัง
ไม่รู้เลยครูเอ๋ว่าอะไร
เปียกว่าสี่เหลี่ยมใหม่นะว่าถ้ามันเล็กลง
[เพลง]
แบบนี้แบบนี้แล้ว
ผู้หญิงอยู่ข้างบนยินหรอคะไม่ใช่อยู่อัน
นี้โลกโลกนะคะโหล
ดาวทิพย์เออโลกอ่ะอยู่ข้างนอกโลก
ต่อตรงนี้มันไม่ยาวกว่านี้หรอก็ไม่รู้
เหมือนกัน
ใช่ดาวเทียมดาวเทียมเข้าใจแล้วดาวเทียม
เก่งมากค่ะคือ
จะโลกโลกโลกผู้หญิงก็คู๋อยู่ที่นี่อย่า
เอาเมย์มีอเมริกามีแคนาดามีประเทศไทย
ยุโรปจีนอินเดียนะคะโลก
อ่ะดาวเทียมครูเอ๋เสือดาวเทียมลอยอยู่ใน
โอ้ผู้หญิงดาวเทียมนี่รอยลอย
ข้างนอกโลกเลยนะใช่
อวกาศทรายค่ะวันนี้ให้
อวกาศเหมือนยานอวกาศรยานอวกาศอีกก็จะมี
แบบ e  t  e นะๆลอยในอวกาศนะเราก็บอกลอย
บนฟ้าเหมือนกันเนาะลอยไปค่ะครั้งผู้หญิง
มีอะไรอีก
เมฆไปแล้วนะผู้หญิงไม่ใช่แม่ค่ะครูเอ๋
อะไร
คาราเซลล์หรอคะใช่มั้ยเค้าเรียกพาราอะไร
อะไรเซลล์ป่ะน่าจะใช่นะคะอ่ะ logout คะ
แล้วก็ล๊อคเอาไว้อ่ะมิ้นท์มีเรือไหมคะมี
เรือด้วยไหมคะ
นี่หนาจากเครื่องบินเหรอคะใช่ไหมมี 2
อย่างนะครูหญิงถ้ามีเครื่องบิน
อันนี้ไม่มีแล้วก็กระโดดลงมาเนี่ยเรา
เรียกว่ากระโดดร่ม
กระชายแต่นี้มันจะเหมือนกับว่าเป็นพลๆภู
เขาอ่ะพี่เอ๋แล้วเราก็วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งแล้ว
มันก็ลอยขึ้นได้อ่ะค่ะเราตรงนี้มันจะแบบ
ใช่คุยไม่ได้แล้วก็จะโดดราดชุบวุ้นเออโดด
ร่มคนไทยบอกโดดร่มชายโดดร่มนั่นแหละร่มนะ
คะลอยได้เกรดใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูเอกคะมี
อะไรที่ลอยบนฟ้า
รอยในอวกาศได้ดาวค่ะขอบคุณค่ะครูเหตุดาว
หรอพี่จอยอยู่ไหนเอาเถอะค่ะ
ผู้หญิงค่ะอะไรต่อไปคิวผู้หญิงอะไรอ่ะ
อะไรอ่ะ
ปลาหมึกแล้วค่ะเก๋ลอยอยู่ในอวกาศค่า
อ๋อจรวดใจค่ะจรวดรู้รออยู่ในอากาศก็จรวด
ขึ้นไปแล้วก็รอยนะคะใช่งั้นตาครูเอ๋แล้ว
ค่ะมีอะไรอีกครั้งคุยจะวัดเหมือนไหม
อ่า
ว่าว
ใช่
เว้า
เว้าก็รออยู่บนท้องฟ้า
ค่ะผู้หญิงขอเชิญค่ะอุ้ยมีรออยู่ดีได้ไหม
อะไรคะอะไรคุยเก่ง
แล้วกันอะไหล่
โอ้ยกูเอกคิดว่าจะคิดวาดกูไม่เอาไม่เอา
ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรอีกบ้านแล้วว่าแล้ววาด
เลยอะหรอผู้หญิงนี้อีกไงไม่อยากได้
นักเรียนคิดว่าใครจะชนะอันนี้
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ลูกโป่งค่ะค่ะ
ชายลูกโป่งลูกโป่งรออยู่บนท้องฟ้า
ตายช่วยเอ๋มีอีกไหมคะอะไรที่ลอยอยู่บน
ท้องมาไปเปลี่ยนสีนะคุยกับเปลี่ยนสีอีก
แล้วเขานักเรียน
พระอาทิตย์ค่ะ
ต่อพระอาทิตย์ก็ประเทศไทยสีแดงนะคะนัก
เรียนบ้านพระอาทิตย์พระอาหารล้อลอยอยู่บน
ท้องฟ้า
กุ้ยมีอะไรอีกไหม
จะหมดผู้หญิงทำไมขยับของคู๋
ขยับได้กูมึงไปโดนนะคะ
คู๋จะรู้ไหมนางอะไรอ่ะ
อะไรอ่ะเป็น
อ๋อเครื่องบินกระดาษ
ผู้หญิงยังว่าไม่เสร็จเลย
เครื่องบินทำไมมีกระดาษ
กระดาษแล้วก็พับพับเป็นเครื่องบินกระดาษ
แล้วก็คุยเรื่องไปใช่มั้ยเนี่ยจ่ายมันก็
หล่อลอยเครื่องไปแล้วก็รอยนะคะ
อะไรพี่เอ๋มีอะไรอีกคะของครูเอ๋ที่รออยู่
บนฟ้าหรือว่าในอากาศอาหารออยู่หรอเดี๋ยว
คุยคิดก่อนอ๋อ
อันนี้โอเคไหมค่ะสีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงิน
f
เปิด
เครื่องมาโอเคเพลงเป็นโอเคสมัยบินแต่ว่า
บิวรออยู่ในอากาศ
ซ้ายได้ค่ะ
นัดหนึ่งอย่างอะไรนะน่าจะได้อีก 1 อย่าง
นะคะค่ะหมดเวลาเหรอคะเราก็ต้องเปลี่ยนลอย
ในน้ำบ้างคะกูเอกกำลังสนุกรอยในอะอะอะอ่ะ
กูยิ่งอย่าง
อะไรคะผู้หญิง
อะไรอ่ะ
กูจะมีขอโทษนะคุณเอ๋ใช่
เฮลิคอปเตอร์เหรอคะอะไรค่ะค่ะ
เฮลิคอปเตอร์
เฮลิคอปเตอร์รออยู่ในอากาศโอ้แล้วก็มีกี่
ได้ๆๆอ่ะผู้หญิงมีอีกไหมมีอีกไหม
อะไรอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงอะไรอ่ะ
โดราเอม่อน
ม่อน
ไข่ไง
โอ๊ยถ้าคุณว่าโดราเอมอนดิฉันก็ Superman
แล้วผู้หญิง
แมนก็ลอยอยู่ในอวกาศได้โอเค Superman
กูอีกผู้หญิงมีอีกนะอย่าให้หมดด้วย
แบบไม่ได้ไปต่อแค่สองคนมาดูกันด้วย
อะไรอ่ะโอ๊ยไม้เท้าไม่ใช่
มั้ยกวาดไม้กวาดของแม่มดเป็นไว้ลอยใน
อวกาศได้
ถ้าคุณเอาไม้กวาดนี้ฉันจะเอานกแล้วค่ะ
นก
บินรออยู่ในอากาศเอกแล้วคอแล้วหยุดตั้ง
แต่
Doraemon
โดรา
ในอากาศ
ใส่ค่ะอ่ะครูเอ๋ไปลอยในน้ำก่อนดีไหม
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงก่อนจะไปลอยน้ำนักเรียนคะ
ครูเนี่ยครูเนี่ยมีมีรอยในอากาศเท่านี้
นักเรียนคิดอะไรได้คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะ
ค่ะนักเรียนว่าผู้หญิงคอมเมนต์ครูไม่มาดู
ผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนหน้าออเจ้าหญิงเปลี่ยนหน้า
คุณครูเอ๋มันยังอยู่ไงอ๋องั้นเดี๋ยวดูวัน
นี้ก่อนว่าตรงนี้น่ะมีอะไรที่ลอยอยู่ใน
อากาศบ้างมาสรุปค่ะของครูเอ๋มีพระอาทิตย์
ราคาพระเอกอะไรอีกครั้งพระจาน
แม่
ดาวดาวเทียมค่ะนก
ว่้า
จริงๆโลกด้วยนะ
แล้วก็
Superman เอ่อลอยอยู่ในอากาศ
2  True หญิง
มีอะไรของผู้หญิงนี่ตอนรู้น
บอลลูน
ยานอวกาศโดดร่ม
จรวดลูกโป่งเครื่องบินกระดาษเฮลิคอปเตอร์
หน้าร้อนแล้วก็ไม้กวาดของแม่มด
โง่ไป
เราไปลอยในน้ำกันค่ะตายค่ะกูเอาออกค่ะของ
กูเองต้องคุยต้องลบใช่ไหมนายไม่ต้อง
เปลี่ยนหน้าเหรอคะรบเอานี้แหละกันค่ะลบๆ
ค่ะลบ
ๆนะคะจะได้ไม่ต้องแบ่งใหม่นะคะ
อ่ะรอยในน้ำบ้างค่ะกลับไปลอยในน้ำราคา
หนาวสีเขียวเหมือนเดิมน้ำราคานามค่ะลอยใน
น้ำนะคะในน้ำผู้หญิงวัดเกาะผู้หญิงว่า
จอห์น
อะไรคะอะไร
ลอยในน้ำนี่ค่ะอะไรคะใบไม้อ.บ้านใหม่ท่า
ต่อถ้าลงมาก็ลอยในน้ำ
ทรายเล็กๆคุยเอาใหญ่ๆแล้วกัน through  a
ค่ะอะไรรอยในน้ำ
เรือค่ะ
พยาบายคุยเอาเรือใบค่ะ
เรื่องใหม่ลอยในน้ำค่ะถึงว่าน้ำเหมือนตัว
เอกก็ได้ค่ะมันจะได้เงินตัวอยู่ในเนื้อ
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิง
อะไรคิดได้ไหมคิดได้ไหมจีบได้หรอ
อะไร
อะไรแครอท
เลเซอร์
อะไรอ่ะ
ขนนกนี่ไงนกใช่ไหม
แม่มีหรอไม่มีกูอีกไม่คิดอันนี้คนโง้ลอย
ในน้ำได้ OK
เหรียญเสมาซามีอะไรที่ลอยในน้ำได้อีก
อะไรอ่ะแมงกระพรุนหนาอัดใช่มันลอยสิ่งๆ
นั้นแมงกะพรุนแมงกระพรุนบางกันก็มีหางยาว
ๆแหม่ๆมันไม่เหมือนกูเห็นลบใหม่เลยมั้ยคะ
ได้ค่ะไม่สวย
ซื้อ
อะไรอีกนะที่รออยู่น้ำขิงต้องคิด
หากผู้หญิงคิดที่ไปก่อนนะคะคุยวัดกับ
คุณก่อนค่ะได้ค่ะเขาอันนี้เป็นหัวใช่มั้ย
หัวแมงกะพรุนหัวหรือเปล่าก็ไม่รู้ตัวตัว R
แล้วก็ลอยรออยู่ในน้ำแมงกระบะ
ท้ายใช่เรามันจะลอยปากบางจะมีหางยาวๆนะคะ
นักเรียนค่ะแมงกระปุกแมงกะพรุนนะคะแม่
รออยู่ในน้ำของผู้หญิงมีอะไรอีกครั้งไม่
มีอันนี้ค่ะ
อะไหล่
ให้รู้มั้ยอะไรแอปเปิ้ลหรอใช่
หรอ
ร้อยร้อยนาจิงปิงเช็คอินเตอร์เน็ตมาแล้ว
ครูเอ๋
ซื้อ
แอปเปิ้ลโยนสิมันลอยอยู่ในน้ำเคยล้าง
แอปเปิ้ลไหมหรอ
[เพลง]
คิดว่านะถ้านักเรียนคิดว่า Apple ไม่ได้
ลอยมันจมก็คอมเม้นต์ได้นะคะเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยว
กูเอต้องไปซื้อแอปเปิ้ลและทำการทดลองรอย
ที่ 1 จริงไหม
คะมีอะไรอีกที่รอยในน้ำอันนี้ค่ะกูหญิง
อะไรคะห่วงหัวๆ
คนอยู่ที่นี่
เคยไปไหมคะพัทยาบางแสนนะคะ
เวลาคนที่ว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นก็มีห่วงยางใส่
แล้วก็เกาะอ่ะแล้วก็รอยใช่ก็รอยในน้ำค่ะ
โอเคค่ะรอยได้ของผู้หญิงมีอะไรอีก
อะไรผู้หญิงมีแตกๆเนาะ
ถึงคิด
คิดไม่จะทำ
อะไรแล้วเราจะได้ไม่ซ้ำกันยายเอ๋อะไร
ไม่ไผ่หรอนี่ไงต้นไม้ใช่ไหมคะต้นไม้เนี่ย
เวลาด้วยหรอคะต้นไม้ปกติเลยขอนไม้อ่ะกู
เอ๋เวลาเราตัดตัดใช่ไหมแล้วก็มาเป็นตรง
นี้เนี่ยมันรอลอยในน้ำได้
เราก็เราก็รอยๆในนามได้
จริงๆโอเคผู้หญิงกูเองนี่เอ๋เอ๋มีอะไรอีก
คะอิอิลอยในน้ำได้
อะไรรู้ไหมไม่รู้
ลูกมะพร้าว
อ่อนมะพร้าวจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะต้นมะพร้าว
เนี่ยจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะๆ
คะแล้วก็มีลูกลูกค่ะรูปมันมะพร้าวและสนับ
สีถ้าเป็นสีเขียวๆนะคะตัดไหมสีเขียวดื่ม
น้ำได้นะคะลูกมะพร้าวท่านหล่นน่ะก็จะรอย
ในน้ำยังนี้
จะเป็นลูกสีเขียวก็รอยเนาะร้อยค่ะลอยลอย
ในน้ำลอยมะพร้าวลอยน้ำผู้หญิงมีอีกไหม
อะไรที่ลอยใน Now
ถ้าไม่คุยหญิงยิ้มแบบนั้นยิ้มแบบซิกแซก
มาก Six แสงเดี๋ยวกูเอกก็ไม่รู้ว่ากูเอก
จะคิดว่ามันรออยู่ในน้ำหรือเปล่าอะไรรู้
มั้ยอะไรน้ำแข็งเหรอคะน้องแข็งค่ะค่ะใช่
ไม่จมน้ำไม่โจมไม่รู้อินเตอร์เน็ตบอกว่า
มันรออยู่ในน้ำเน็ตออกเอาจริงๆลอยค่ะใคร
จริงลอยคือเอกไหมอาบน้ำแข็งอย่างนั้นแหละ
ค่าน้ำมันจะรอยนักร้อยค่ะน้ำแข็งค่ะรู๋
คิดออกไหมคะมีอะไรอีกที่รออยู่ในน้ำอ้า
อ่าเดี๋ยวนะเป็นแบบเนี้ย
อะไรอ่ะยาวๆแล้วก็มีขีดขีด
R  R เซิร์ฟบอร์ด
นางหาไทยๆๆๆภาษาไทยภาษาไทยยาวมากคนไทยก็
ลืมกระดานโต้คลื่นอ่ะนะคะ
กระดานโต้คลื่นนะคะการโต้คลื่นก็ลอยอยู่
บนน้ำค่ะผู้หญิงมีอะไรอีกไหมคะที่ลอยอยู่
บนน้ำ
อะไรอ่ะเกรดใช่ไหมไม่รู้เป็นสี่เหลี่ยม
แล้วก็มีพูด
หาแล้วก็จะมีสี่เหลี่ยมอีก 1 อันแล้วก็
สี่เหลี่ยมอันนี้ก็เถอะ
อะไรอ่ะจิ๊กซอมาต่อกันใครๆจิ๊กซอว์แต่ไม่
ใช่จีนเลขออกช้าใช่ตัวต่อ Lego
เหรอคนไข้ก็จะเอาอะไรก็ไปโยนลงน้ำ
เลโก้มันตกน้ำมันก็รอยได้
คุยถึงอะไรปวดหัวปวดหัว
ตัว A มีอะไรอีกที่รอยน้ำได้ตากนี้ค่ะนัก
เรียนขา
วันเพ็ญเดือนกระทงเองค่ะกำลังเลยเนี่ย
ประเทศไทยนะคะในเดือนในเดือน 1 พฤศจิกายน
ที่ประเทศๆมีคนไทยทำกระทงนิเรียกว่ากระทง
แล้วก็อาจลอยในน้ำ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงคิดอะไรอ่ะ
มีอะไรอีกผู้หญิง
ขวดใช่ค่ะขวดน้ำขวดพลาสติกลอยในน้ำได้ไม่
โจมมีอาใช่ๆไม่เถียง
ก็ได้จริง Apple น่ะคู๋สงสัยนะคะหนู
อินเตอร์เน็ตบอกกูอีกยังมีอีกเคมีอีกไหม
คะอะไรที่ลอยในน้ำได้
รองเท้า
เก๋ต้องมานั่งเรือแน่ๆเลยอ่ะเวลากูเอง
นั่งเรือแล้วก็เห็นมีอะไรรออยู่ในน้ำ
ลอยอยู่ในน้ำได้อย่างนี้อีกไหมคะหรือยอม
แพ้ยังมีเวลาใช่ไหมคะ
มันเป็นยังไงหรออะไรล่ะคะ
อะไรอ่ะมาเล่นแล้วโพสต์
เรือกล้วยจะเอาเป็นสีเหลืองให้เลยเขาก็
เรียกเปิดนาน่าโบ๊ทไม่ได้
พูดเรือกล้วยเหลือกรวยก็ได้ค่ะเรือกล้วย
Banana  Boat ค่ะวันนั้นอาวุธลอยอยู่ใน
น้ำได้คุณมีนาน่าโบ๊ทดิฉันก็มีตัวนี้ค่ะ
มีอะไรคะครูเอ๋เอ๋
ที่ 9 อย่าก้าบก้าบเป็ดก้าบๆ
เป็ดว่ายน้ำก็รออยู่บนน้ำ
ใช่ไหมไอค่ะ
ผู้หญิงมีอะไร
อันนี้ค่ะ
หวีล่ะคะ
ใจนิยายผู้
เหี๊ยวัดเล็กก็เก๋ไม่เข้าใจ
เดี๋ยวๆมีขวดแล้วมีฝาขวดเหรอคะอันนี้ฝา
โค้กอันนี้เนี่ยขอค่ะป๋าโค้กไงปากคบกันจะ
เป็นแบบนี้เป็นเหมือนสแตนเลสลอยอยู่ในน้ำ
ได้
โอเค
อีกได้คนละ 1 อันใช่ไหมคะได้คนละ 1 ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋อ่าผู้หญิงจะรู้จักไหมอ่ะพอดีว่า
เต็มแล้วดูสิแค่คุยวัดใหญ่หรือว่าตรงนี้
แล้วกันได้ค่ะบางทีเป็นแบบนี้
ไหมใบที่เป็นแบบนี้
แค่เนี้ย
อะไรอ่ะบางครั้งเป็นกลมๆเป็นยาวๆเอ่อครับ
เขาเรียกว่าลูกกลับทุน
มันเป็นมาจากต้นไม้หรอคะมาจากต้นไม้หรอคะ
ก็แม็กซ์ไม่ใช่ทำจากอาจจะเป็นเชื่อแบบนี้
หาเป็นเชื่อเป็นฟรีกินเป็นพลาสติก
เอาไว้ติดที่เรือค่ะ
เปลี่ยน 4 ตัวนี้ละกันน่ะสีอะไรดีสี
แดง
เขาจะเอาไว้ถูกติดกันเรือท้องแล้วเรือก็
ลอยน้ำได้
We  Are เข้าไว้ในเรือเวลาเรือนจอดนะคะ
ตรงนี้เป็นท่าเรือค่ะท่าเรือเรือจะจอดก็
ต้องปล่อยลูกกระพรุนนะคะตะลุงกลับคุณกู
เอกก็พูดไม่เอาไว้ไม่ให้เรือกระแทกกับถ้า
เลยอ่อเรือจะได้โอเค
ทายนะคะลูกกากกระพรุนก็ลอยอยู่ในน้ำนะคะ
ผู้หญิงนิ่งอย่างตัวเองอะไรคะ
อะไรอ่ะ
ดอกบัวหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะคือตัวเองอุ้ยชอบกิน
นะคะเอาไปผัดอร่อยมากผักบุ้ง
ซ้าย
ผักบุ้ง
ผมขอผักบุ้งได้น้ำไงมันก็รออยู่บนน้ำ
ไม่ใช่ลูกคุณไม่พูดผิดลูกกระเพรา
โกหกแดง
จะเหมือนกันก็คือที่กูอ่ะพูดก็คือเอาไว้
อยู่กับเรือใช่ไหมลูกกะเพรา
รู้กับเหาอันนี้เวรน่ะเอกพูดอะไรผิดไหม
ทั้งหมดนี้คือรออยู่ในน้ำของครูหญิงก่อน
ก็ได้เนาะค่ะค่ะเอาของอ่านก่อนน่ะของครู
หญิงมีใบไม้
ขนนก
แอปเปิ้ล
ขอนไม้
น้ำแข็งค่ะตัวต่อ Lego
ขวดน้ำฝาขวด
Banana  Boat แล้วก็ผักบุ้งค่ะพี่รออยู่
ในน้ำ 2 ครัว any อะไรบ้างโอ้โหหน้ากูเอน
นอนแล้วเพิ่งตื่นมาเนี่ยนะคะไม่มีรองเท้า
นะคะ R สีแดงรองเท้านะคะอ่ะ
เป็ดค่ะอากระดานโต้คืน
อะไรนะอ่าอ่ะกระทง
ลูกมะพร้าว
ค่ะห่วงยางแมงกระพรุน
RE เรือไม้คะแล้วก็ลูกกับเขา
ไปถ่ายรูปกะเพราไม่ใช่ลูกกับคุณลูกลูก
ตะเพรา
โอ้ยเหมือนแมงกะพรุนเวลาดูมันก็คล้ายๆแม่
ก็พูดเนาะลูกตะเพรารูปกับเพรานะคะหวยกะ
แมงกระพรุนใบกับพระเข้ารูปกับรูปตะเครานะ
คะมีรูปกระเพราเรืออยู่ตรงเนี้ยค่ะอันนี้
ก็รออยู่ในน้ำนะคะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก
ของที่ลอยในอากาศลอยในท้องฟ้าแล้วก็ลอยใน
น้ำนะคะไทยค่ะโอเคป่ะหมดเวลาแล้วเนาะหมด
แล้วตาเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะ
คะค่าสวัสดีค่ะอ่า